Vision hubs right that's right I'm also
the last man on Earth whose computer you
want to be hacking into you just earned
Yourself A Dance with the Devil boy
you're under arrest like I said I'm here
for the team that crippled my
brother there ain't no goddamn team it
was just one man and he standing right
in front of
you
the lady was
right you are a terrible
Li
h
God damn my team
guys on
me
[Music]
Lea
HS
I have eyes on
tett
[Music]
Sha's in the way and it seems our
friendship is at an
end do
it thing about street fights
the street always
wins I will beat your ass like a
Cherokee
drum maybe one day we'll find out oh you
better hope that day never
comes I said no Mr Nobody I'm not
leaving this cell I'll get out my
way the right
way get back to yourself it's just a
malfunction get back just a
malfunction
got going up like
[Music]
that blast Back In The Cut like
that I've been waiting a long time for
this keep waiting
rubber bullets big
[Music]
[Applause]
mistake like
BL
[Music]
knock
that took longer than I
expected
go for a
ride back in a
sec where's that smile there it
is
[Music]
you going to shoot a
baby you sick
bastard you're not going to want to see
this is that you or
him him good
bag the
asset
[Music]
Now or Never I'm more of a now type of
guy my three sure 1 2
3 no one tells me what to
[Music]
do
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
on now I take you to school
[Music]
son remember the hallway no guns right
those guys have to be alive because at
the end of the hallway the retinal
scanner needs a match to open the door
pick a door all right there no that's my
door it's better with
you I made a mistake this is your door
oh no no baxis what's the matter you got
a lot of bad guys behind that door
watch's this you might learn
[Music]
something
get
[Music]
a
enter corresponding
match access
deny access
[Music]
deny this
access
de access access
[Music]
access access
granted doors
opening I was beginning to like you to
you know
that oh
well
[Music]
what's the problem boys does it
hurt must be hard being
so
[Applause]
human
[Music]
you see that work together we can hurt
you're right time to work as a team
there two of us and one of him I'll take
a punch and let you land one I'll do the
same
got your back brother and I got yours
let's go unplug this son what
[Music]
we
go
here comes the cryptonite
oh